what's up guys Jerry here coming at you
live and direct on a Wednesday evening
and you know what I've realized lately
is that there's nothing quite like a
devastating natural disaster to bring a
family together you know what I mean
just crippling damage to infrastructure
whole city is caving in buildings
collapsing you know tsunamis there's
nothing quite like it when it comes to
family bonding and that's exactly what
this movie brings us because I'm talking
man about san andreas that's right the
new action adventure disaster joint
starring none other than Wayne the rock
Johnson and I gotta tell you guys I mean
this movie you know coming out of the
movie is pretty intense san andreas you
know is a textbook example of a
big-budget Hollywood popcorn disaster
movie this is a math equation this movie
with mathematical precision you know
hits all the required moments all they
required beat some notes all the stock
characters are represented you know all
the stocks scenes plenty of destruction
to feast your eyes on it it is a
textbook example of what this kind of
movie looks like and it's orchestrated
with precision you have Dwayne Johnson
as your very charismatic lead who is
dealing with some past traumas you know
his wife and daughter are estranged
they're moving in now with mom's
boyfriend and that's a strange situation
that gives us you know sympathy for them
and it makes us root for them
want to see this family get back
together man carla Gugino is his
well-meaning wife and alexandra daddario
is his normally do this but she is
ridiculously gorgeous and she's also his
daughter she's heading off i think to
college or something like that and you
know when the big one hits you know
they're all in different places in the
movies basically about watching them try
to get back together and also hopefully
salvage their relationship as a family
on then you know on the flip side you
have the other story which is Paul
Giamatti and he's this very dedicated
Caltech seismologist him and his partner
have just discovered you know fault
lines we didn't know existed and they're
finally reaching a breakthrough in there
sort of pre-emptive earthquake detection
technology things happen people die
romance ensues and it's you know you're
basically watching them deal with the
immediacy of this disaster going from
point A to point B to Point C to point D
and how they do that amid various really
striking disaster sequences and I mean
the effects of this movie are pretty
great um we saw it in 3d and this
tourneys pretty good I mean it's all
right um I'm not a big fan of 3d myself
so maybe you'll dig it more I feel like
in these really effects-driven movies
the 3d makes things look a little more
CG or a little more fake to me sometimes
but you know this movie is exactly what
it is and it works you know I mean I
wanted to see the family come back
together I wanted to see Dwayne Johnson
triumph I wanted to see the romance
ensue between Blake and Ben his daughter
in the young British dude who's charming
and befuddled and one thing I do have to
definitely give this movie credit for is
the same approach that made the disaster
sequences of Godzilla's so striking to
me is the same sort of approach they
took in this movie which is for the most
part when things are happening when the
big earthquakes and the big disastrous
moments are striking they put you and
the camera in places where people could
be for the most part there are a few
wide shots you know showing the city but
there's nothing that's so far removed
from like a physical human perspective
and that makes all the big set pieces
really kind of upsetting especially you
know if you're familiar with the layout
of LA at all or if you've been near tall
buildings you know it's not hard to
fathom when things are shaking and being
destroyed and collapsing and crumbling
it's intense you know there was
hand-wringing and uh you know there was
a lot of that and I gotta give them
credit for that because it makes this
movie effective it's really well
orchestrated for that sort of purpose
and also you know this is a pg-13 movie
but it does do a good job I think I
noticed in little places these movies
aren't allowed to be bloody but there
are things in the backgrounds of scenes
where that do kind of communicate you
know the scope a lot of people die I
mean let's be honest in a movie like
this those buildings are crumbling lots
of people are dying and there is at
least I sensed an effort to you know at
least put some people in the backgrounds
and stuff like that you know bleeding
and whatnot now that I'm saying we got
one is great but you know it does give a
certain hint of real disaster to this we
are used to seeing the aftermath of
disaster and this movie sort of
incorporates that in a decent way I mean
this movie isn't anything new it's not
anything particularly inspired it just
knows what it is and it spins that wheel
with precision it plays itself pretty
straight but the appeal of dwayne
johnson is that he
we can ground a movie and good-natured
miss and you know all the performances
are pretty much on point I like Carla
Gugino I liked alexandra daddario a lot
the two actors who play been an ally the
sort of romantic interest in his little
brother they're really charming there's
a lot of chemistry between everybody the
math is all there the only thing that
really kind of rubbed me wrong about
this movie is their treatment of the own
Griffith character who plays Dwayne
Johnson's soon-to-be ex-wife's new
boyfriend I just thought they could have
handled him in a more sophisticated way
instead of making him like the one kind
of despicable [ __ ] you know I thought
they handled him in a really kind of
petty way with as much good nature as
the movie handles most of its characters
with they just sort of make him hateable
and I think this is kind of a shallow
choice to make but that's just me you
know this is a film for whom you will
most certainly have to suspend your
disbelief i mean movies like these are
about worst-case scenarios this is a
worst-case scenario if ever there was
one and you know Paul Giamatti as the
seismology expert you know he really
helps to sell the stakes as convincing
and then on the flip side Dwayne Johnson
you know his persona and just as
charisma and his confidence help to sell
you on the idea that maybe one man could
rave all these elements to bring a
family back together and ultimately it
is exactly what you think it's gonna be
pretty much I mean it is popcorn cinema
by all means this movie isn't you know
groundbreaking it's not pushing the
boundaries it's not anything new or that
we haven't seen before san andreas
really is a dyed-in-the-wool resilience
in the face of insurmountable disaster
working class hero right down po2 the
American flag unfurling at the end but
it's a large-scale disaster movie that's
very adept at what it does a lot of
technical proficiency went into this and
it's well assembled it's a well-oiled
machine and it's got enough charm and
charisma to make it engaging it's kind
of good it's it's terrifying at times
it's not my favorite kind of movie this
isn't the thing that I love about cinema
but you know I can get down with a
popcorn disaster movie and this movie
did its job for the most part with
pretty flying colors so yeah let's talk
about this you know what's your favorite
disaster movie
Fenny cuz you know we don't get these at
unusually it's some kind of sci-fi thing
but this is just you know I guess this
is still science fiction in a way but
you know it's a more natural sort of
thing it's not space aliens so yeah
what's your favorite disaster movie
let's talk about that um yep till next
time san andreas is the film my name is
Jerry Cheers